well good morning everybody sorry for
the delay and welcome to the meeting of
mid suffolk development control b
committee may i first of all please read
some domestic arrangements please do not
interrupt other speakers or hold
separate conversations whilst others are
speaking if you are attending the
meeting to speak and persistently
interrupt the meeting you may be asked
to leave please ensure your mobile
phones are switched to silent or
switched off we will be using the
e-voting for this meeting on the modern
gov app so please could members make
sure they are logged in and ready to use
the app
fire safety arrangements if you hear the
alarm leave the building immediately via
a fire exit and make your way to the
assembly point ipswich town football
ground
following the signs directing you to the
fire exit at each end of the floor do
not enter the atrium which is the ground
floor area and walkways if you're in the
atrium at the time of the alarm follow
the signs to the nearest fire exit use
the stairs not the lifts do not re-enter
the building until you are told it is
safe to do so
the council members of the public and
press may record film photograph will
broadcast this meeting when the public
and press are not lawfully excluded
introductions area planning manager
gemma walker
legal advisor ian duprey
case officer jasmine
wild good morning governance officer
alicia norman
and we have mandy here who's steering us
on the electronics
we have ward member councillor andrew
mellon
and i think it would be polite to
introduce all our other members we have
councillor muller councillor gould
councillor casten councillor war boys
councillor norris and councillor
stringer and
your good selves at the back are the
general public
some are applicants agents and you may
speak if you have requested to do so
so if i move on to the agenda please
apologies for absence and substitutions
do i have any apologies none received
yet
to receive declarations of disclosable
pecuniary interests other registrable
and non-registrable interests by members
are there any to declare
councillor stringer thank you i have a
non-registered interest in the item
item two i think it is bacton thank you
declarations of lobbying any lobbying
none to declare
declaration of personal site visits
please only to declare
and that is on item
two thank you very much
confirmation of the minutes of the
meeting held on 18th of may are there
any points to the accuracy of the
minutes
can i have a proposal please
councillor muller and councillor casten
would appear to be the seconder is that
correct
thank you
can you conduct the electronic vote if
you would please alicia thank you
thank you chair members that vote is now
in progress
council manager you want me to take your
vote verbally
hello cancer stringer
thank you chair that seven votes four
and one abstentions that is carried
thank you very much
order of play the first item is
withdrawn so we move directly on
to the second item
and
we'll ask jasmine to introduce the item
please if you would which is
a discharge of conditions application
for dc 1900 646 condition 12. it is a
condition thank you
and just as a note i will sign the
minutes later on thank you sorry carry
on justin
thank you chair and good morning members
i'm presenting a discharge of conditions
application today in relation to
condition 12 of outline permission
dc1900646
condition 12 specifically relates to
highways works under the backton railway
bridge and on pound hill and along broad
road
just to recap outline planning
permission was granted in december 2020
for the direction of 65 dwellings with
attenuation basin
the full wording of condition 12 is now
on screen but to summarise the condition
requires that prior to the commencement
of works details of footway improvements
under the railway bridge and along the
frontage of broad road must be approved
by the lpa
no dwellings can then be occupied until
the highway improvements have been
delivered
importantly such highways works will
also be subject to a section 278
agreement with suffolk county council
highways which is secured separately
from the planning process
such agreement will deal with the highly
specific and technical nature of the
footwear improvements including safety
audits and their construction
this is an unusual application to be
presented to members and the reason it
is being presented is on the basis of
discussions that occurred when members
were presented with the reserve matters
application
in particular there were concerns raised
to
raise as to the safety of such
improvements
by way of updates suffolk county council
highways have reviewed a technical note
that was submitted alongside the most
recent revisions to the layout in
response to a stage 2 safety audit on
the proposed highways works
suffolk county council's updated
comments are included on the most recent
email exchange which has been handed out
to members
the issues um that were raised as part
of that stage two safety audit and
within the um accompanying technical
note have been addressed firstly through
the installation of reflective bollards
or safety railings along footways
and secondly through removing the
curbing on the south side of the bridge
um south of the south side of the
footwear under the bridge
and replacing this with cross hatching
just to remind members of the site and
the context here we have the site layout
that was considered under the reserve
matters imposed on an aerial image
the access into the site is shown by the
green arrow
pound hill is to the south with the
circle showing the railway bridge
the site is to be connected into the
heart of bacton in several ways which
are secured via condition 12. firstly a
two meter wide footweight is proposed
along broad road which would link into a
proposed widening of an existing footway
on the corner between broad road and
pound hill
and finally a new two-meter footway is
proposed under the railway bridge which
will connect to an existing footwear
either side of the bridge
here we're looking eastwards towards the
site
which as you can see highlights that
there is a lack of pedestrian and cycle
supportive infrastructure currently in
place
here we're looking westwards into the
centre of bacton as you can see many
vehicles including vans are shown on
screen tend to marginally straddle into
the adjacent lane and because there are
currently two
lanes running under it
members will note that the low height of
the bridge is well displayed by neon
yellow and that is restricted to 3.1
meters in height
for context this would mean that no
large hgvs can use this route currently
as they are around three three and a
half meters in height
and a luton van is around the maximum
height of around 3.1 metres
as shown on the earlier slides there is
a lack of infrastructure to support
walking and cycling in the vicinity
as an example any parents with children
as you saw on the earlier slides
walking currently from the site or
indeed from the eastern side of pound
hill along this route towards the
primary school within the centre of
backton
are put at particular danger as there is
only a small informal dirt area present
either side of the highway and those two
lanes
this currently encourages people or at
least provides them the opportunity to
overtake any pedestrians or cyclists
under the bridge
in terms of the physical changes being
made to the highway the proposal seeks
to narrow the highway to one lane under
the bridge which would provide a minimum
width of
303.75 metres
zooming in on the previous diagram you
can see that you've got that um dark
grey area is the road then you've got
the green is proposed footway
and to the south is an over runnable
area
this in effect pushes cyclists to the
middle of the road
but enables larger vehicles to pass
through where required by using that
overrun
here is the cross section of what the
improvements under the bridge would
essentially look like the two meter wide
footweight is accommodated on the
southern side which subsequently narrows
the road into one lane
a new priority type layout would be
installed noting that the lanes are
being narrowed to one lane
and road markings will um make it clear
to users as i'll show you on the second
slide
and priority will be given to those
traveling west westwards along pound
hill
so alongside the physical alterations in
the highway there will also be increased
signage and road markings to make it
clear to users so as you can see you've
got the priority signs
and as well as sign labels on the road
notably the highway code encourages
cyclists to be within the centre of
narrow lanes in order to increase their
visibility and reduce potentially
dangerous situations
at present there are two lanes under the
bridge as you saw on the earlier photos
which currently enables drivers
and affords them the physical space to
overtake cyclists the proposed highway
improvements would ensure that there is
only one lane with a clearly demarcated
overrunable area
and as such cyclists will naturally be
shifted into a seamless central position
within the road until they're safely out
from under the bridge and the road then
will go back into two lanes
currently this situation as you can see
on that left-hand side um enables
potentially for cyclists to be pushed
further towards the side of the bridge
which again obviously increases the the
safety risks
it's important to note crash map data
in terms of the existing situation in
regards to safety under the railway
bridge so crash map data over the last
22 years shows and suggests that there
has only been one recorded slight
incident which was in 2013.
the other element of the condition
requires footwear improvements along
broad road to remind members this is the
access into the site that was considered
under reserve matters
members previously expressed concerns
with the removal of hedgerow hedgerow
along the northern frontage
this has been retained with only a small
portion either side of the access
requiring removal or cutting back
which is shown by that red circle
looking south from the site you can see
that adequate visibility is achieved and
there are no hedgerows like there are to
the north that will require any sort of
works
the new footwear will start from the
southern side of the access from the
site leading south to connect onto pound
hill
so this is so the bottom um photograph
there will be where there is a widening
just to the side and then how that
curves around towards the site and then
you can see where it connects into an
existing footwear which then leads to
the railway bridge
in summary the proposed highway works
offer betterment to the existing
situation and would improve pedestrian
and cycling infrastructure and
associated safety in relation to active
travel within the locality
the recommendation is therefore one of
approval
thank you chair
thank you very much um it might pay to
put one or two of the um
slides up showing
the the proposed
things so do members have questions for
the
planning officer at all
anybody not clear on what's going on who
would like a question council of war
boys
thank you chair um
yeah earlier
it's just to clarify really and it's to
do the um
the curbs
i think early on in your presentation
you said that the
the top
uh pedestrian way was going to be
replaced by
um
crosshatching
and then we had a cross section of the
railway bridge showing curbs on both
sides
and
further on
uh it's page 116.
the over runnable area as a 25
millimeter curb upstand i'm just not
quite clear
where the kerbs are
i am a little concerned about the curve
over the other question are you
concerned about it sorry yeah i just
need to clarify my mind where curves are
and where they are
uh thank you yes so in terms of there
were some um amendments made as part of
that technical note that came in
um so there was concerns over the curbs
being proposed which potentially could
be worn away by larger vehicles
obviously the chances and frequency of
those larger vehicles using that
potential over runnable area is limited
by the height of the bridge anyway
and
what has been proposed subsequently is
that there's a kind of cross-hatching
area the surfacing material is to be
confirmed by the section 278 agreement
with highways
but essentially you have the footway and
then you will have an over runnable area
which will enable
obviously the larger vehicles to
go over it if need be but generally will
it will be avoided so it will be within
the highway rather than the footwear
so there'll be curves on both sides
i believe so yes excuse me can you just
clarify was it curbs or was it cross
hatchways there's going to be uh cross
hatching
no curbs
no
i thought that was a slip
it's all right
no no you asked the question and we need
it clear so that's that council stringer
thank you yeah i was going to ask is
there a drawing that shows that because
frankly there are several drawings that
are conflicting in the
public documents and the documents
supplied to committee so
you said this is the latest drawing
is that in the committee bundle
or is that a new one
so
in would it be fair to say that
sometimes we do get late papers which
this obviously clearly is indicating
which obviously members are more aware
of as we come to a committee meeting
so i believe what has happened is this
is the earlier revision which might be
available on the public file
there's a couple of drawings which have
been put onto the reserve matters public
file rather than the discharge and
conditions application which we will be
rectifying
in terms of the earlier revisions i
believe that there was a blind spot
noted because the visibility on the
existing um
situation was taken from the middle of
the cab as if there was an hgb
what's then subsequently come forward is
that the visibility has been
altered which then demonstrated that
there was a blind spot which has then
been addressed
through this overrunable area
there might be some further plans which
we'll obviously look into and make sure
that we have got everything and there's
no discrepancies
but i don't believe anything has been
submitted currently
hang on
i'm sorry sorry so we haven't got the
plan
of what we're being asked to agree to
the officer is advising what the update
is and we often as you know counsellor
have an update on the debt
but we normally when we're being asked
to agree something have a plan of
exactly what it is we're being asked to
agree but i think we can understand what
the planning officer is saying would you
agree
sorry this on the screen is the most
up-to-date one and i think as per the
recommendation i think it's on page on
page 116 in the bundle that is the
amended plan of the 23rd of may which is
also the plan from the recommendation
which talks about the overall area yes
okay so then that that's helpful
so can i then there's two questions that
arise from that is the cycle
now we've identified
after the existing four plans that were
submitted the group of four that you
just shoe which isn't in the bundle
we agreed that there was a blind spot
there that the county officer
had agreed when he came to site that
there was indeed blind spots here
so they needed to be addressed what
stops the cycle if it's merely an
overrunable area from getting into that
blind spot
i think the answer is nothing would
physically stop them going into the
overrunable area
but
obviously it's in the interest of a
cyclist to be on the smooth part of the
surface as opposed to an over-runnable
area that's clearly demarcated it would
be in their interests
for their own safety to be
within the centre of the the carriageway
as per the highway code
can we not have a debate sorry i'm sorry
just a minute just before you go on um i
think we have got a late paper from ben
chester which identified your problem
that you were just bringing up now and
um so when we go into debate we might
have more discussions about that because
it's clearly been addressed
thank you
okay
oh right okay i didn't think it had been
okay sorry the
the
issues of what you can see and what you
can't see as a driver is dependent on
the speeds there were two elements to
the original drawing that were incorrect
it was the sight line from the the
driver there was also the stopping
distances were incorrect
can you tell us what
average speeds are being used to
calculate the stopping distances and
thinking distances because of the blind
spots somebody needs to make a call as
to whether to be able to stop or not and
they need to be able to do that in a
safe distance and i was just asking what
data we've used to calculate that
i believe the data that has been used is
just
scroll through
so i don't know if you can see but it
says at the bottom so this is the 85th
percentile at 33.4 miles per hour and i
believe that this is the information
that has been used by suffolk county
council
obviously when they come to do the the
section 278 works they will have to
carry out their own safety audits in
terms of stopping distances and and
whatnot
and and that that will then subsequently
inform
what then gets constructed
but this is where we are currently in
terms of understanding
how
cyclists and pedestrians would be able
to access from the site into acting
so can we be careful that we're not
entering debating no you've asked your
question and also it does say that ben
chester says it's also noted that the
stage two road safety audit team have
accepted the amended proposal so i think
there's been some calculations that
maybe perhaps aren't up there i don't
know that's what they did indeed accept
the first one right so any further
questions
council and norris thank you
thank you very much
uh i notice in the papers it mentions a
reduced uh road width of 2.75 meters
under the railway bridge and that's also
mentioned in the email from ben chester
that's been just been circulated but
when the slides came up i noticed there
was a different measurement shown i
think it was a slide previous to slide
14.
could you just clarify that please yes
i don't know if mandy you're
brilliant thank you
it's that one isn't it
yeah so in terms of um the carriage rate
i think
where the 2.75 meters has come from is
the narrowest point because obviously
it's not uniform throughout the the
whole bridge so that's kind of the
maximum
and then you've got 2.75 meters which
includes the over runnable area
thank you very much um i have a question
um
have you been on site looking at this
because i know various meetings have
taken place with the um
county members and um
locals and the ward member and
highways
and that's appropriate
but have you been on site were you
invited to any of these meetings
i haven't personally been invited to any
of the meetings and
i'm not the the case officer although i
am presenting um i am however very
familiar with this area and i did
actually go to school at backton so
i'm i'm very familiar with the the
railway bridge that we're discussing
today
okay
okay yes so
yeah okay thank you very much um
right
so um
oh yes counselor melon sorry i was i was
about to talk to you anyway that's fine
thank you chad um
my i just got a question on just to
clarify on the edging on the footway
because i think uh one of the first
slides showed
it would either be rail or some other
measure
can we just confirm what is what is
planned there is is that
to be agreed during the section 278
yes yes so that will be agreed um via
the section 278 works but in terms of
whether there will be
some form of measure there to prevent
obviously any pedestrians kind of
entering the the highway it will either
be
those um bollards or railings so it'll
be subject to agreement at a later stage
but
there will be something
yeah i mean i think my concern is less
pedestrians entering the highway more
vehicles entering the footwear
but if there's something there
that would be good
thank you councilman before i do come to
you we do have present uh james wellam
the agent his colleagues alan brackley
and matthew downham
um now they're not going to speak the
presentation
has been presented obviously but if any
members have any further queries that's
not been clear
if you have any questions we have an
opportunity
to ask anybody require anything
no
no
fine thank you gentlemen for coming
nonetheless um so councillor mellon it's
now um your opportunity to tell us about
this
uh position here thank you
thank you chair um
so members will be aware there's a
fairly long history to this um the
bridge has been here for a long while
the road has gone under it for a long
while
and with it's always been the case that
um we've been told that there is not a
safe and implementable scheme
uh under this bridge to get pedestrians
there now we have a planning application
which
is bringing forward a scheme
so the bridge is on a bend in the road
and also to this
the rail line and the bridge cross the
road at an angle
so that the bridge is kind of slightly
cranked across the road alignment so
it's a particularly troublesome
situation because of the angles
and the way you come at the bridge and
the viewpoints through it
but the current situation is not good
there's no protection for pedestrians so
you take your life in your hands trying
to walk under the bridge
so
um
improvements here are a good thing
but
it needs to be got right
and hence this is why we insisted that
this condition be examined carefully
and i think we've been vindicated in
that we're right to do so because the
officers have acknowledged that the
initial plans
for this scheme were not
optimal
now whilst local members do we don't
bring
professional highways expertise to the
discussion
what myself and councillor stringer as
the county councillor do bring is the
detailed local knowledge we know this
bridge we know it's problematic and the
issues here need to be
satisfactorily resolved
the problem actually is not overtaking
under the bridge the problem here is the
potential for cyclists to
meet a vehicle head-on
so there still remains concerns about
cyclists traveling east to west under
the bridge
given the angles through the bridge
a vehicle traveling the other way west
to east could meet a cyclist head-on
that's why there's the need to push
the cyclist out from the verge into the
sight line of the motorist approaching
them
now so far that makes sense
but then you see on the plans uh
page 160 of the bundle's got it the the
build-out is not actually a out
due to the fact that buses and other
vehicles have to be able to get through
so we need this over runnable area
and that over runnable area does have a
curb but it's only 25
millimeters
now 25 millimeters
is not enough to deter a cyclist from
using this area
and potentially then they could go on
into the over runnable area and not be
seen from the other direction
so what stops the cyclist going on to
that area cross hatching or whatever not
sure
in correspondence only yesterday
the proposal was made by the county
officer that this over runnable area
could be paved with a textured surface
such as granite sets
and that would
deter cyclists
but
fine i agree this could work
if we could maybe ensure this by
condition
however i still have concerns that the
design of this scheme is being amended
and altered up to this point without it
going through a full safety audit and
review
or consultation so um
where am i coming to with this i would
really encourage members of the
committee to be absolutely certain that
they are happy with what is approved for
this bridge
simply accepting the highway authority's
word unfortunately has not proved
correct through the process so far
so i would recommend that members
consider a site visit
have a look at the bridge the roads the
angles
hopefully with a highways officer in
attendance to advise
so that you can be really sure that the
design is right thank you chair
thank you very much
questions for the ward member please
there are none thank you
we go into debate please counselor
muller
uh thank you chair um well having sort
of seen all the various arguments for
this over several planning meetings i
must admit having seen this latest paper
this morning
from highways
i think this is actually a pretty good
proposal in this particular case
and in view of that i'll be happy to
move
that we actually uh do approve the
actual proposal as stated in the
office's papers thank you chair
so for clarity you're proposing i'm so
happy to propose chair thank you thank
you do i have a
phil yes
cancer
sorry the the recommendation in your
papers is hardly um a model of clarity
i'm afraid and
following discussion uh
between uh general and myself we think
it's appropriate to
simplify that so that you have clarity
about what's actually being asked here
the um proposal that we'd like to put
you there for is that we simplify the
recommendation um in the following way
such that we simply ask you that the
committee express or confirm that they
are minded that the amended details
on plan reference 9980 jnp 90 drc
2413 rev po2 submitted 23rd of may 22
which is the drawing i believe that
jasmine had up a moment ago is the one
referenced in your papers
are acceptable in discharge of condition
12 in relation to works under the
railway bridge
and secondly that the chief planning
officer have regarded this committee
resolution in determining the discharge
of condition application
dc
2201655 so it's a slight tweak which
hopefully simplifies
the recommendation just before
councilwoman proceeds with this
in essence it does the same thing but it
it tries to make it a little simpler
thank you
right okay i couldn't write quick enough
on that um bearing in mind that that
is the proposal i think would i i don't
want to put words into your mouth but
would i be correct in thinking that what
you've seen and heard
would
uh in your mind
something you wish to to um support and
with council with um philip isabel's
amendment makes it clear
um would you still be happy with with uh
proposing it yes thank you yes i'll be
more than happy with the proposal made
by the chief planning officer chair on
that i personally don't think there's
any need for a slight visit i think the
diagrams the pictures we've actually
been shown perfectly adequate and i
would be happy to sort of you know
continue with my recommendation that we
we approve what chief planning officers
just recommended to us okay then um can
i have a seconder for that proposal then
please
counselor gould
very much yeah i'm i'm grateful to the
uh
chief planning officer because i think
the
um
the rewording of the recommendation does
bring
uh clarity both to um
the decision we're taking and actually
our our role in that in that process i'd
i'd also
uh like to uh applaud the efforts of
those
um
the local council is in involved
in uh securing these these
uh were manifestly great improvements to
scheme and
not only they brought improvements but i
think and sometimes this is hard to do
they have demonstrated the value and
importance of the democratic
side of the of the
planning process
[Music]
like councillor
this is clearly had um
a very
uh thorough
uh
consideration um and i'm conscious both
of that
local knowledge but also of the
of the statistics that the data that's
been
presented in terms of the background
risk here
i'm grateful also i'm very grateful this
morning for many things but including
the advice now received from the
highways
from the highways officer
about the
the
their satisfaction with the with the
plans
and
expressed in a way that only highways
engineers cans we are not in a position
to object to the proposal which i think
is an endorsement of those it's clues
saying that these are right i'm also
aware that the actual arrangements are
subject to a separate
agreement under 278 being an essay
between the highways authority which
isn't a matter for us but it matters for
them um and and the applicant so it
seems to me i was sorry to miss the
um when this previously uh was was
considered but it seems to me this has a
thorough
uh going over and i'm very happy to
support the
the proposal the recommendation
thank you very much now and people
wishing to speak councillor stringer
yeah thank you uh
i would uh i won't be voting on this but
i will make an observation in those
on the application i first knew about
this bridge in 1971 when i was part of a
protest wanting to get a footpath under
this bridge and the county council
position at the time was there is no
safe or influential scheme under this
bridge
fast forward to 2007 under the school's
organisational review for backton when
we were going to close the middle school
we were asked what improvements we could
have for
upping the amount of school transport by
sustainable means we said can we have a
bridge a path under the bridge we were
told there is no safe or implementable
scheme
in 2016 the planning application was
proposed to build some houses
and the county council changed its mind
to say to say there is a scheme possible
underneath the bridge to improve walking
pedestrian cycling safety
so we asked could we see a plan
and today as we sit here about to agree
this we still have not been shown
a plan and a drawing of what is proposed
to be built here to do it
we did have a set of plans in pursuant
of this
condition
and it contained a report which is not
in your bundle which it really frankly
should have been
that show those four scenarios that were
possible to make this happen how the
sight lines of the vehicles would not
put people in danger
myself and councilor mellon went on site
to check those drawings physically
we found that the stopping distances
were not there they'd been exaggerated
by 20
and indeed the sight lines have been
calculated from a driver sitting on the
handbrake not sitting in the driver's
seat
which increased the amount of visibility
under the bridge
as soon as we saw that we spoke to the
case officer who was very sadly not not
in at the time because of family illness
we did speak to the highways offered to
say look you've signed this off he'd
already responded to our planning
application saying this is safe i have
no objection we called him out to the
site he then agreed he'd never been to
site he then agreed that in fact three
out of four of the scenarios proposed
under this bridge were quote dangerous
and the fourth one was only possibly to
be safe if the speeds unilaterally
dropped to 21 miles an hour
the average speed under that bridge
today with zero accidents by the way
with pedestrians under the bridge is 34.
that is a massive assumption to make
which is why we pleaded that you the
committee see the plan that's going to
happen so you can be assured it's safe
before you say yes
and all we're being shown at the moment
is some diagrams that might be this
might be that and a verbal assurance i'd
fully trust our officers in the verbal
assurance but what i don't trust is the
system this committee approved some
section 278 works in fish bonsai hawley
nine months ago
the scheme has now been built the
footpath been built has now all been
ruled unsafe by the county council and
cannot be used because it's dangerous
that is not what can happen here so i
would if i was on the committee and i
was voting
i would be voting to go and have that
site visit so you can have that plan in
your hand and make sure that what you
are going to approve is not going to
kill someone because that is the
potential consequence you are going to
you are you are making traffic
becoming head-on with cyclists coming in
another way where they can be living in
a blind spot and that frankly i have not
seen a drawing that addresses that to
have an overrun which is merely a bit of
paint or a different service service is
frankly not good enough and it's still
evolving even as as soon as yesterday as
amendments coming in from the county
council officers say well we could do
this and we could do that i really
really would urge you to make sure
before you say yes thank you
thank you councillor who else would like
to speak
councillor warboys thank you
thank you chair
um
yes i i
i'm beginning to understand the
principle of this um
the cyclist traveling
into this bridge we'll have um right of
way so the curb and everything is
designed to push the cyclist out into
the middle of the road which is now
single carriageway
and laurie's coming the other laura's
vans vehicles coming the other way will
have to give way and i'm assuming
there's going to be adequate signage to
show which
direction of traffic has right of way
as a very infrequent cyclist
i wouldn't feel very comfortable with
this i would be very comfortable with a
race curved pushing me into the center
of the road
um
can i just stop you there can we just
get clarity on that it's not raised is
it
no no so it's not wrong so it's not
raised on either side
sorry i can't
i'm a bit left
no it's it's not raised
so the only thing that is would be
directed me out into the middle of the
road would be
a marked level of
over runnable surface
yes so in terms of the overrunnable
surface the details of that surface and
how it is constructed
are matters that will be considered
under the section 278 agreement with
suffolk county council highways and
they have said as per um council
mellon's comments in correspondence
they've said that it potentially could
be a different surfacing or something
that very clearly demarcates that it's
an overrunable area and not the highway
just before you carry on because you
clearly have
your time to stay i think mr isabel just
wanted to interject on that point
um yes thank you
in other cases where this has been done
in the county you've typically got and
they're known as frangible bollards in
the sense that you can knock them over
and then put them back the typical bard
arrangement is collapsible so the impact
is not a stop
but it effectively allows you to
decelerate into into a bollard but where
you've got other arrangements that are
like this
they've been used in two other examples
that the county have provided to us
elsewhere in
in suffolk
of the overrunable area as as examples
sorry you're you're busy telling us more
about your your position but you're
having a debate at the same time i'm
having an internal debate
just to help us a little more with your
thoughts
yes it's this drawing on page 116 is is
not applicable at all
because it actually says over runnable
area with 25 millimeter curve upstand
infill to rear
it doesn't say anything about bollarding
um the point i think councillor melanie
and councillor stringer have made about
the evolution of this drawing and
describing it's
the fact it shouldn't be um that you
shouldn't have had to take this i mean
as with any a lot of designs you do see
matters evolve as
i mean planning is an iterative process
you learn things you change what you do
the latest i have from the county uh on
other examples shows bollarding as a way
of
both providing um
attention to something and drawing
drawing traffic out
um
you know that's that's not detailed on
that right
that's not shown on that drawing but
yeah you know that's that's one option
that's available to demarcate that area
so counselor no counselor stringer no
there's councillor war boys then
councillor um
casten sorry blaine's got carry on
cancer warboys we interrupted you and i
do apologize
yes um all right so as a cyclist
approaching this bridge on my left hand
side
i may be seeing a line of bollards
i'm wrong
did you want to interject that you were
just giving an example so i so what i'm
referring to there are two examples that
the county council have given to us of
an overrunable area elsewhere in the
county where at the entry and the exit
of that
in reduction in width
bollards have been used to indicate
the narrowing but you nevertheless
underneath have underneath them on the
surface of the carriageway a
an over runnable area with curving which
allows you to run over it so it's it's
effectively you know at or close to
level
um they're not necessarily shown on the
drawing as it sits today
but clearly you know if members feel
that that signage is important that's
something that members can instruct us
to go away and resolve
um
i i'm not sure what what counselor
stringer knows about discussions with mr
chester on site but that's
in the example he's given me of other
cases where this has been done in the
counting
so do you wish to continue further
cancer wall boys we interrupted you at
beg your pardon
that's fine um
you know with the health and safety um
concerns with regard to this and being
asked to
agree to something and pass something
and i have every faith in the case of
the planning department
but i have a bit of a doubt in thomas on
this and i would actually physically
like to see
what it
it it actually entails um
as i said i'm an irregular cyclist and i
would and
my natural instinct is to
follow the curve as it were rather start
cycling into the middle
and
as a
you know i would like to reassure
cyclists
from their point of view that this
is an acceptable
proposal
so at present the cyclists just drive in
the middle of the road would that be
correct
i think they would
or they could get knocked off by traffic
at the moment so it's a bit of a
dangerous thing at the moment i think
i i i think the pedestrian footpath on
the
i forget what we've said is it's the
north side the top side is it is a
tremendous improvement
but i am
i'm not quite convinced about this from
the cyclist's point of view right so i
am i am
okay i'm happy with it
right okay that's fair enough and and
that's very clear your reasoning thank
you
did you want something put up on the
screen here chairman if it would help
can we put up a slide of of the current
scenario just so we clear
the situation we're looking at and the
break yes
yeah um and and i do speak as a cyclist
who who has regularly cycled under this
bridge so i know that of which i speak
and there is no footwear you know and
the question of forward visibility is
and you know every vehicle cyclist
carriage
needs needs to
you know it needs to be aware of the
restriction the uh the attention of of
the height restriction in the bridge
thank you very much madam chairman i
think this um
this is a um a difficult situation the
bridge and the road can't be changed at
all so
i asked myself
is this a better design
does it um protect pedestrians more yes
definitely
um i am a cyclist does it protect
cyclists more yes it does the um
i i'd much prefer to cycle under this
with it being one way that's a massive
improvement
and um
to be able to get in the middle of that
so you're not in any of the dark edges
hidden away or anything is a massive
improvement the um
you get rid of the potential um for
accidents um on there the um
i'm really confident that the chief
planning
officer
with guided by experts
and um
highways and all these people that deal
with these kind of
situations all day
um are capable of dealing with this yes
i think there should be a definite
change in material or
an obvious side to that road and there
will be i'm sure there will be so um
yeah i'm
i'm i'm happy i don't think we need a
site visit
um
i think this is
something that the chief planning
officer can
can deal with
thank you very much um
council stringer did you want to go
before councillor norris because
yeah yeah please do thanks jeff yeah uh
i just want to sort of address the thing
about the bollard that
the reasoning
there's been this evolution is because
of the original problem you've got a
finite amount of room under the bridge
and you're trying to push through it
varying uses and trying to make each of
them safe
and each of the differing uses has a
consequential impact on the others
which is why we've seen the evolution of
this application for reserve matters i
don't share your confidence james i'm
sorry and the facts prove it on this
case
the original drawings the county council
signed off as safe
were ruled unsafe within a week once
they came and looked at it
if you if you think that's giving you
grants for assurance
you're a lot more optimistic than me but
i'm looking at the facts of this case
they've got it wrong once they can get
it wrong again
within the next week or two so there is
that element of of that trust is misled
in this instance the other thing about
the about bollards or no boilers the
problem we have we thought they'd solved
it 10 days ago and they came up with a
hard curb edge and we were promised a
build out to get those cyclists into the
center of the road they then realized of
course if you put a build out in there
you can't get the buses through safely
so
because you can't then erode the two
meter footpath there simply is not
enough room and not enough sight lines
so we're now talking about overrun areas
the problem with the overrun is if a
cyclist can access it and it's merely a
bit of paint that the lorries and buses
will wear out very quickly
you are putting those cyclists in that
place you don't want to be which is
false confidence
knowing that the only traffic now going
west east is on the wrong side of the
road
that's the important bit if one cyclist
can get in that blind spot
with the person not doing 21 miles an
hour voluntarily still a 30 mile an hour
limit here
you have got the head-on that you really
really should not have that is the point
why site visit would allow you to see
those sight lines and that those
drawings that we haven't yet actually
seen a drawing of is actually true on
the ground thank you chad
thank you councillor stringer councillor
norris your turn please thank you
thank you
uh yes well i
do have a number of concerns regarding
this application um
i think the
having an overrunable area to me to a
certain extent
negates some of what was being proposed
i'm not convinced
that this is a
finite solution
there are a number of
instances that i can envisage where
bones etc are not going to wait for a
cyclist if he gets into the overrunnable
area
i do think this is something that we
perhaps ought to go out and say for
ourselves
before we
make the decision that we are asked to
make
so i would suggest that we have a site
visit
thank you thank you for that counsellor
right well everybody's had their speech
and now i look at this
now i've been very grateful for all the
input from every counsellor here today
of what things are about
i've looked at this plan and i looked at
it obviously in briefing and had it
explained and
i looked at it very carefully in
paperwork and on the screen
i hear the passion in which everybody is
saying that cyclists will be at danger
cyclists um are being forced to do this
that and and the other when they cycle
which i understand
our suffolk lanes are quite difficult
and at our jubilee the other day
we had a road closed sign
and we had trestles right down the
middle of the road in debenham
and a bunch of cyclists came hurtling
through
pretending to steal sandwiches off the
off the tables weaving in and out of
people and saying the queen would be
happy with this and cycled off
so i think cyclists have a
responsibility to cycle safely
now i understand from the ward member
and councillor stringer the passion the
involvement the amount of work i do
agree has gone on
however i also remember on another case
that we were told they couldn't possibly
get a crossing at stowe upland and that
was by an ex-highways engineer on the
group couldn't possibly be done
and it was done and it's done safely and
i have to say i crossed it first of all
when it first went green and that is a
secure and safe
transit so that was brilliant
i just wonder whether that
sometimes we all have to take
responsibility for what we're going to
be doing but equally we need to be sure
that this is going to be delivered
delivered on time and safe
and i have confidence because i don't
know who else we can turn to apart from
our highways experts
to look to these designs and i hear i
wrote it down
that there were the issues where it
wasn't possible it wasn't possible it
wasn't possible but sometimes people
think outside the box and they've come
up with a very good design it must be
better to have a footpath for the
current people that are walking through
there it must be better and i do think
as a driver when i see
a sign saying someone has right of way i
do slow down i know what these suffolk
lanes are like we all do so i'm quite
happy to support this
so we've had a proposal in a
second but
mr isabel you wish to
comment i was going to say we need to
have it read out exactly
what
we are looking at here
and i think we need that
uh read out before we go to the vote is
what i was about to say thank you
um
so
we just so we're clear the
recommendation to you makes reference to
a drawing number
and
the recommendation that we're now
proposing
simplifies what was in your papers
and i'll read it verbatim
the committee confirm a that they are
minded that the amended plan the plan
details plan reference 980 jnp 90
drc2413 rev po2 submitted 23rd may 2022
are acceptable in discharge of condition
12 in relation to works under the
railway bridge and b that the chief
planning officer have regard to this
committee resolution in determining the
discharge of condition application dc
2201655
and i will say something on
acceptability if i'm may chairman
the county
highway engineers have advised us that
the scheme is satisfactory in mitigating
risk
one cannot rule out risk on the road the
decision a planning committee makes is
made on balance
that's
actually 50.1 percent it is not beyond
reasonable doubt
so from our perspective as officers we
recommend to you
a position that is based on the advice
of the professional engineers
which as we understand it
reasonably mitigates the
risk as i say i have cycled under this
bridge many times myself i i am familiar
with a number of issues
this addresses pedestrian
safety in a way that does not presently
exist it cannot and no highway scheme
can ever completely rule out risk
whilst i have heard the local view i
have to say one as a committee
you must be minded that your decision
must be on balance
rather than beyond reasonable doubt
satisfaction
and i will leave it there chairman
thank you very much and with that in
mind then can we go to the vote please
thank you chair members that vote is now
in progress
thank you chair that is four votes for
one against and one abstention
thank you very much going down the
agenda do we have any site visit
requests
none to report you
in that case then i will close the
meeting thank you very much
you